this time we all dance on the Incredible
Dr pole Happy Thanksgiving we're not
just talking turkey are you hanging on
or hanging on we got llama drama their
instinct is to mount any animal that's
laying down oh and they ki hard they
it's all about animal attraction I love
you too and that's no
bow meet Dr Yan pole he's a local Legend
with over 19,000 clients and a team that
does whatever it
takes we had a couple of turkeys running
around the neighborhood for about the
past 48 hours and who do you call do you
call Animal Control it's not like
there's a loose dog on the run so I
thought why not call Doc Paul I just had
a phone call for three turkeys on the
loose I'll pick them up yeah what are
you going to do with turkeys
Thanksgiving is right around the corner
mom I've always wanted turkeys and if I
have a chance to own three of them I'm
going to take that chance Charles has a
big heart can't you tell he loves
animals I don't think we'll have turkey
for Christmas I know that turkeys okay
yeah going the turkey hunt good luck
turkey hunt
bye going to get some turkeys going to
get some
turkeys as soon as Charles sets out to
rescue the turkeys to get some turkeys
Capone rolls in with a major laceration
on his left
hoof Capone was laying down I saw there
was a lot of blood my heart
sank I thought I'd have to put him
down what happened I believe he got
caught on his back past turn on the bar
Boer fence I can't get the bleeding to
stop ohy easy easy easy the horse is
very painful easy step I got you good
boy boy good boy so the thing to do now
is just to just follow me give it the
shortl lasting anesthetic lay it down
and see what I can do oh my gosh oh it
wasn't good when he unraveled the
bandages that was hard to
see a that is right into the
hoof when I look at it that is not barb
wire this looks like it was the steel
that's on the side of a barn steel
siding on
barns is a killer for
horses this is a life-threatening
injury the cut has nearly severed the
entire
hoof the sooner Capone is anesthetized
oh buddy just a sharp needle and off his
feet watch out the sooner doc pole can
try to save his hoof look at
this oh my gosh oh Dr Paul was very
honest about how bad it was if this
comes off he has a malformed hoof and
he'll never walk again no holds bar tell
it how it is is that's him the cut has
cut the whole hoof from top to bottom
the back end is still attached and I
hope to keep it attached but we don't
know for sure that it's going to happen
or not a song of a dance and a big
prayer and go to church for the next 10
weeks okay we'll write that down in the
case like this I think I could pull it
together got nothing to lose so what I
want to do is take a big suture material
and pull that skin together I'm going to
Sut you that
together as tight as I can get it that
is always risky because you may not get
new hoof especially with the injury was
so it's a it's a chance that you take
but I definitely won't give up that
easy I used the the very big needle
because that skin is very thick and
tough come on get through that
gosh dang you here don't sit there grab
hold of the knot so then I had her help
me and hold the first knot so I can get
the second one on top without it
loosening up got it mhm Bingo I'm a
nurse so he let me help him when I
needed to and I wouldn't expect any less
okay one more time
here if somebody wants to the time and
effort in there to help an animal heal
up I definitely will go along and help
them out as much as I can
okay I like working together with people
like that we can always put the horse
down and the whole hoof falls off in the
meantime let's try to see if it if it
heals up and if it can save the horse
Okay me thinks that should be it this
hopefully will knit together and you
know when this roove comes in and you
see it knitting here then you have to
make a slit here so that that crack
doesn't go all the way through through
okay I hear Dr Paul never gives up which
is a good thing best move I made was
coming to Dr Pole looks better now it
did good job good job not no let's see
two months three months from now be
right back you remember that mirror you
fixed our and got hit by the car yeah I
did exactly what you said after you left
you couldn't even tell I know they're
horses okay here worst case scenario is
that the coronary band is not making no
hope
okay okay and that she always going to
be lame put your foot on top of each
other there best case scenario 3 months
from now there's new hoof growing out
and the horse is just
fine today was the
hardest it's all uphill from
here it's going to take Capone a while
to sleep off his anesthesia but for the
moment doc pole has done all he can do
we got a phone call earlier today and
they said somebody had turkeys in their
backyard that didn't belong to
them yeah the turkeys are on the loose
again oh perfect I don't know who they
belong to looks like two females and
there was a third one there was a third
one but my neighbor said he saw some
feathers in the yard so all right well
we'll see if I can get my hands on them
Hur right I hope that he will be able to
catch the turkeys and maybe keep them
domesticated and I don't want any of the
dogs in the neighborhood to get them
turkeys are definitely interesting
animals and if I have a chance to own
three of them I'm going to take that
[Music]
chance got some help yeah if you could
help me just by holding on to the bag
okay if he packs me ni oh watch his wing
I'll help you but if he pecks my hand
I'm out of here not that I run that
easily but I just didn't want to get
hurt there we
go don't worry
buddy they're beautiful turkeys tame
they're long-legged Majestic animals
with quirky
sensibilities and I can identify that
well if you see the third one let me
know and I'll come back okay all right
perfect thank you all right you're
welcome well I'm looking for a third
turkey here oh there it is
and that's the mail Charles located the
last Renegade
turkey gobble gobble
gobble but something is definitely wrong
oh boy that's got to
hurt he got attacked by a dog probably
it's a good thing this guy's new home
you're fine comes with a full-time
vet it looks like a serious chunk taken
out of him he's lucky he would have been
a a dead turkey if if I hadn't come
along I just hope he can hold on until I
get him back to the
clinic meanwhile back at the clinic come
on get up Capone is having some post
surgical Munchies come on we got a boy
up you go what yourself Amy got it and
he's still a little wobbly from the
anesthesia God dang good news his hoof
is no longer bleeding you come with me
ah now he's ready to get loaded going
home come on buddy let's go come on come
on get that boy come on many of these
kind of groy horses here we go no do not
want to step up on the trailer okay give
me a hand what we do is we just lock
hands behind them and lift them in oh
yeah you're heavier than I am come
on oh man uh this one was a little too
big for that so know we what we use is a
rope
you tie it to one end go through the
other side and just pull CU a horse
doesn't like to have a rope underneath
its tail ready come
on the nod suddenly gave out no problem
I still bounce
back that didn't help much you come on
tide Dr Paul is a spring chicken he got
up and he isn't going to let anything
beat him yeah that's a cotton rope that
doesn't hold you know if you make
yourself a laugh and start laugh with
you know that's a lot more fun than
laughing at him come on Capone not what
we expected so the next time there was a
a good night in the RO come on and the
horse were in come on there you go thank
you any questions call me two to three
weeks on the sutures right yeah at least
he is going to be sore for the next few
days I'll keep him comfortable the best
I can in a stall so he's not out routing
around like he would want to be so it's
a long road for
him doc Pole's son Charles has just
rescued three stray
turkeys calm down calm down one the
victim of a serious animal attack needs
immediate attention you take the wings
lay it on its back two legs oh my it
can't live like that no it's not dead
but it would
[Music]
die Charles is on a rescue mission he's
rescued three turkeys hey buddy hey
buddy calm down calm down the newest
editions to the Po's ever expanding
managerie you take the wings lay it on
its back head one the victim of a
serious animal attack oh my Charles got
his foot in hot water again he picked up
three turkeys he brings the one to the
clinic and there a big hunk of skin
coming right off his chest this has to
be cut off it can't can't live like that
no hang on for a second for this
emergency surgery doc pole relies on an
old school
technique it looks strange you know but
tape the legs together tape the wings
down move move move cover their head and
they just lay
there okay this is the way I was taught
to do surries on on
birds the skin in these birds is not
very s sensitive and that all that was
there you know it had a big hunky skin
hanging there that was so dead already
you just cut it off you think you can
sew back together dad mhm that's what
you're doing right now
Charles oh wow that's quite an in wow I
never seen a turkey quite like that
before like what that uh injured and
still
repairable you know me don't you I'm a
fixer I know I fix makes anything and
everything I know now listen here it
comes you hear it that's the stomach
remember the gizard with all the stones
and the food in it right now that's the
sound it makes wow I've never heard that
no cuz you never been that close to a
turkey usually they don't let you get
that close usually you see turkeys all
wrapped up in
plastic
help it's too hard to find white
stitches in white feathers for
me stitching up this turkey quickly
turns into a family affair right there
it's on the oh shut up get out of there
I had one supervisor and one assistant
that wasn't doing this job they're like
Velociraptor claws well one freaking me
out are you hanging on or hanging on it
just started well I she knows I'm done
then you untape the wings and you set it
up then you untape the legs and it just
gets up and walks away now see now it'll
sit
up see there you go see that's how you
do it Char do it the oldfashioned bay
and get it done today I feel like a hero
I save some turkeys one of them was
definitely going to die without my help
the other two probably would end up some
dog's dinner hey buddy now I have three
turkey pets I'm excited about
it oh no I'm sorry Goble
Goble Charles isn't the only one swept
up in the Thanksgiving
Spirit today rescues are coming in all
shapes and sizes two dogs are Great
Danes they look pretty rough so I assume
that they have been at large for quite a
long time where these dog came from
nobody
knows you're a big boy yes you are two
boys
no hi there we've been dad's out called
all the vets in the last two weeks
nobody's claimed them yes personally I
cannot believe that somebody that lost
two D would not really try hard to get
these dogs back so it looks to me
somebody didn't want them you in the
play don't you yeah and they were the
sweetest dogs
ever but these are really nice guys I
have a weak spot for Great Dan so
instantly I fell in love with both of
them you guys need one or two don't say
that with oh yeah here I would say yes
yes I'll take them both right
now it's like kids there's always room
for one
more young sit unfortunately whoever had
the dogs before trimmed the Tails cut
them way back and they had done it
themselves because there had been no
stitches put in yeah and the owner did
it very strangely the Tails were cut off
that is not what we do in Danes normally
and it wasn't done by a feter neither
nor stitches in other words and let it
heal the dogs obviously had been
neglected so easy possibly because the
taals have been do like they were they
might have been used for dog fighting
get up they're not yours they could
be I was kind of hoping he and Diane
would fall in love with one of them and
take him in what a dog he's having a
tough time Diane I know until we got the
last ones as it happens my friend's
parents are looking for a great day and
so I'm going to give them a call and let
them know that there's a dog here
looking for a new
home hello Charles called and told us
that there were two dogs that had come
into the clinic that were great AES I
think that this could be a good match
I'm a little nervous and I'm a little
excited and and I I can't wait okay
great I'll look forward to hearing from
the next with Charles playing Matchmaker
it looks like these guys will have new
homes by
[Laughter]
Thanksgiving the Petersons are here
today with three
llamas all with an uncontrollable
urge I'm here to have the llamas
castrated their instinct is to try and
mount any animal that's laying
down we have 58 sheep nail llamas will
lie down with the sheep and turn to do
their thing with the sheep and uh it can
be fatal morning I check it up doc it's
cold out here llamas
llamas this one gets a shot llamas will
hit with the front leg will hit with h
leg so they kick forward backwards and
they spit yes he does for all their
Amorous intention towards the Sheep
these are definitely friends with
benefits they are very very possessive
of their little friends they will make
friends with the sheep and uh they will
protect those sheep wrap the thing right
around the gate there it seems like when
you get a bigger animal that makes
friends with a smaller animal they have
a a tendency to protect it just hang on
with that we have coyotes around here
and all he has to do is just come
running at the coyotes and they're on
and that's the main thing what they do
changes their attitude probably a little
bit not too much it doesn't make any
difference whether they are castrated or
not because their protective Instinct
does not diminish with the hormones okay
he's done he's walking a little bleed
though you
would little guy goes to the gate we'll
get a rope around him one day said was a
miniature llama i' never seen it looked
an awful lot like an alpaca oh and they
kick hard don't they they do have one
heck of a kick on them I can vouch for
that cuz why they got a hand in my mouth
[Laughter]
yeah the the mini lamb I also had mini
testicles and it takes a little bit
looking for it just got through the skin
pull the testicles out crimp it and let
it go I got this and I always get my
balls you don't want that you're not a
meat either
these llamas are castrated and
everybody's doing just fine huh so no
more llama drama at the Peterson
household across town Dr Brenda heads
out to her first Farm call of the day
today I'm at Stratton to do some
dehorning it's fall time it's time to
get the dehorning done before it gets
real cold and
nasty I've got seven cattle I need
dehorned kind of concerned that I've got
a couple that are going to be a little
feisty trying to Wrangle seven Cavs with
only three people is a risky
proposition a single Blow from one of
these guys can be
fatal Dr Brenda decides to set up a few
safety barriers swing this in that's
good there we're using the facilities we
have it's not the prime set we would
like to have but we're going to make it
work today let's put that gate
there ready ready I'm going to get I
guess most of the time dehorning is done
for tradition's sake for safety sake of
a cattle so they're not beating each
other up certainly it's safer for the
people that work with them if they don't
have
horns the horns will get a good 2 in
thick they'll Gore you the crap out of
you if you cut them now you don't have
to ever worry about it again and they
they sell higher if you sell them
without
[Music]
horns oh it's ble out of his nose yep
it's cuz we' got the sinus open okay so
when I taken the horn off we got a hole
in the head that's into the frontal
sinus all right and to be done problem
yeah okay we're done with this one
everything is going without a hitch
until pork chop arrives on the scene
pork chop got her name because she's so
thick we haven't had a calf ever that's
been that thick so we just thought that
name fed her well she's not very tame so
and pork Chop's eyes were all
danger this is not very safe for any of
us hey hey because you could literally
run over
us Dr Brenda on who's next is dehorning
a small herd of cattle it's been a
smooth process until pork chops
turn she's decided to make a break for
it
this is not very safe for any of us she
could literally run over us she looks
like she's wild and crazy right now
she's busted through the fence and now
is running around the pasture it's just
frustrating for the owner and for myself
it means we're it's going to take us
longer to get our job done can we run
her right along the fence and zip her
right in this pen cuz my intent is sort
of drive her down that fence line there
and then one of us drives them down
drives her down P but we'll wait till we
got everybody where we need them to be
yeah hands out of your pockets and ready
to go
right now we're basically a defensive
line of humans trying to act as gates to
convince this heer that she needs to go
back in her
pen up we were going to run her down the
fence line so she couldn't turn but
without a few more people it was kind of
hard so she got away from the fence on
me and booked it out to the other
pasture unfortunately for us today as
we're working with pork chop there's not
enough of us to make a solid line of
people hey hey oh I think that pork Cho
is going to get get the best of us today
okay we're done yep we're done okay she
didn't hurt herself and I don't want her
to but yeah we'll get her up here when
she calms down tonight
yeah so we've managed to get six out of
the seven calvs de horn today they went
fairly well we have had one slight
catastrophe with pork
chop we'll dehorn on a different
day pork chop isn't the only one on the
Run Charles's three new p at turkeys are
busting a
move did you see your turkeys out there
he's running around loose Charles has
given these guys a new
home but it looks like they prefer to be
free
range they go on walkabouts that's what
they do they can walk miles in a day you
guys are too far from home you're not
supposed to come all the way out here
they haven't wandered too far but it's
going to be probably a battle of wills
here for the the next few days what do
you call a naughty turkey guys dinner
and with Thanksgiving just around the
corner they better listen up yeah yeah
yeah I know eventually they'll learn
that this is their home and anything
outside that is out of bounds all right
you guys stay naughty
[Music]
turkeys after rescuing two abandoned
Great
Danes Gail wett decided to keep one and
and with the help of the poles found a
new home for the second here we go for a
walk today we're going to adopt Zeus out
we found a home for him through Dak
pole sometimes it's difficult to find
somebody who really is looking for a
great day and a great day that needs a
home and pairing them together it's a
good
feeling I'm Deborah stankovich this is
my husband Richard and we're here to
adopt a great a Charles called and told
us that there were two dogs that had
come into the clinic that were great
danes oh my God look at him he's
gorgeous and then we saw this one and he
just stole my
heart I think his name's going to be
Jackson he's
beautiful if he wasn't adopted in 30
days he would be put down and he's such
a beautiful animal I just couldn't see
that happen he deserves
better it's
perfect it's only difficult because I'm
going to miss him it's it's not
difficult because I know he's going to a
good
home he's a good one I'll take good care
of him don't worry what kind of warms
your heart and brings tear to your eye
to see something like this happen hang
on there I think he's ready to go yeah I
think so that's the whole purpose is to
you know help the people and help the
pets this was definitely going to have a
good ending before Jackson heads to his
new home in New York state he'll be
stopping at the clinic so doc pole can
give him a final once
[Music]
over one place where everybody's giving
thanks year round hello little mama is
at Christine leco she rescues neglected
and abused
horses animals they can't speak for
themselves so that's one of the reasons
why I took these horses in and I'm doing
the best I can for them and I want them
placed in good
homes doc pole is here today to work on
three of Christine's new
arrivals Let's Get Busy okay the mini
horse was one that we P blood of it for
KAG KCK me okay take all your blood
Kagan test is a test for equine
infectious anemia I call this one Rascal
and there is no vaccine and no cure
she's 13 13 once Rascal gets a clean
bill of health Christine can start his
adoption
process okay she's done she's done
tell's open up next up a little
castration he's got very tiny ones one
is up high with so many horses living so
close together it's a precautionary
safety
measure I've never seen this done so
pardon me I want to see it a lot of vets
will not allow you to watch that they
don't want you to see what they're doing
you watch it watch it watch
it we all dance you know that's like me
if I drink too much that's why I don't
drink anymore I don't
either he's a high flanker he should
never have been breeding that skin is
here as thick as elephant on his
knees hang on Charles this horse was
also one that was rescued and uh they
said it was a good stallion but to me it
wasn't first of all the testicles were
about half the size and that was because
they were very tied up to the belly wall
man are they high
flankers these conditions are hereditary
and you should not breede with these
kind of stallion I don't know how a heck
you ever got any pregnant cuz these
testicles are way too small yeah they're
tiny good
throw oh boy he's rolling his eyes at
me what did you
do okay let's go to the old
horse come here baby come on Spirit the
final patient of the day has suffered a
lifetime of neglect yeah look at you
pretty girl it was one that was in bad
shape we guessed that it was like close
to 30 years old the teeth are bad and if
the winter gets bad they suffer you're
so beautiful Hopefully Dr pole can
figure out if he can save her life we
need to do what's humanly possible for
her
yeah
come here baby come on Spirit Christine
leco runs an animal
rescue yeah today one of her beloved
horses spirit is facing the consequences
of a lifetime of serious neglect and
malnutrition yeah I seen that she looked
miserable and unhappy and she didn't
deserve that you're one beautiful lady
you know that we guessed that it was
like close to 30 years old the teth are
bad and there is no way that this horse
can come through the winter and feel
good you don't have to worry about the
starving no more these horses are
outside in 20 15 10° weather and they
just stand and shiver so in the case
like this when when there's no way that
you can get a body condition back up
it's time to
go it's killing me it's it's a
heartbreaking decision but I have to do
what's best for these
horses you know I can't prolong their
life unnecessarily if they're going to
suffer okay you never seen me do this no
I've never seen this two shots oh sweet
then they just lay down I come with a
needle like this I go directly into the
heart they gone lots of anesthetic so
basically they don't feel anything and
then you know they just go to sleep
stocking feet already too yeah if there
was any hope for her oh watch it watch
it watch it watch it she's going
already don't fight it
honey it's hard to watch somebody go
through a lot of pain and you're
standing there you you
connect there are certain occasions
where you cry along with your
patience but at the same time you want
to be stoic you know they're looking for
you for a shoulder to cry on not to be
crying with them yeah but I just like I
said I couldn't leave her in that in
that
position Let It Go honey you're
ready there she's gone you're
free people like Christine that that
rescued these horses they just have a
big
heart spirit she's given me that will to
fight for horses for for saving another
horse Thanksgiving is only a few days
away and the forecast calls for
snow before Jackson a newly adopted
great danne hits the road to his new
home hello oh hi he needs needs to make
one last visit to the clinic the new
owners brought jackon in this morning
come on Jackson come on buddy the tail
had been cut off by probably the
previous owner it did not heal very well
so we're going to have to do some work
on the tail hi Jackson a quick shot of
anesthesia ready yeah and Jackson's
ready for surgery he's heavy holy
mooses did somebody just take like one
of those trimmers to his tail or
something I don't know how old he was
but somebody just whacked the tail right
off man of life he would not leave the
tail alone I feel bad for him he must
not have had very good owners Char
somebody mutilated this dog look at this
how raw it is this poor dog has bone
sticking out right here so what I'm
trying to do cut it here cut that bone
off pull the skin together rough tough
dirty okay I'd like to know who did this
I'm going to put his tit in the ringer
too that piece of bone has to come out
and then I can get the skin over the top
do you have a saw
Yes okay Charles now it really depends
on
you here look at this Dian
listen that's bone y I hear son of you
know sometimes you should
swear okay
now
we getting that hear
that now does the skin go over the top
yeah you're going to pull it towards you
yeah okay hang
[Music]
on grab a hold of the knot yeah pull
pull at least we got that point out that
was taken out oh yeah that looks
decent
that that holds there
[Music]
go it's together it is Jackson's tail is
fixed easy now he just needs to sleep
off his anesthesia pick him up I got him
then he'll be heading to his new home
are we ready yeah in New York
[Music]
state oh come on
Charles there's no doubt it's going to
be a snowy
Thanksgiving but this is one turkey who
won't be making it for
dinner he answers to Turk Turk and he'll
come running across the yard for that
when he can it's a shoe he was always
attracted to shoes boots are favorites
okay I don't know why he'll come running
from anywhere to come visit the boot I I
don't get it but it's his
Joy Turk Turk may have a serious foot
fetish but lately he hasn't been feeling
very light on those feet at home he has
problems just getting to his feet in
water that's that JY soup oh
no let's pick him up on the table not
only is Turk Turk having trouble walking
he also seems to be really packing on
the
pounds I feel all this this fluid here
you feel it here to
and that's why he's so heavy yeah we
were actually wondering how he was
getting heavier because he hasn't been
getting up there you go you know that's
because he's retaining fluid let me
listen to his
heart stick it in your ear something's
terribly wrong that's way too fast with
Turk Turk's
ticker after some massive weight gain
and trouble walking Debbie Peabody
brought her pet turkey to see Dr Paul
stick it in your
ear too hard that's way too fast now I
know why it's heavy because it's
retaining fluids because he's got a bad
heart his heart is just and it's close
to 200 congestive heart failure for my
turkey I never anticipated anything
wrong with his heart I thought we were
here for his leg I'm going to get you a
pill okay we put him on a little
diuretic and see if he can get those
fluids out and he can move better but
it's a jerky who knows it's a Band-Aid
it's not a fixer right but if we can
make him feel better that's all I'm
after edible mm-m oh he's not edible
anyway he's off he's off the menu oh
shut up turkeys are meant for the plate
so I'm I'm one of the few that keeps him
for pets and I wouldn't change it he's a
good friendly
bird half pill a day okay now with
proper medication Turk Turk should stop
raining fluids there you go and be light
on his feet once
again I'm excited that I get to keep my
turkey Turk Turk is lucky he's heading
home but doc P's next patient Maddie may
not be so lucky hi girl Maddie is kind
of sick and when I looked at her I found
a tumor on the base of her tongue way
back in her throat and that hurts and
that's why she can't eat that's why she
can't even swallow I'm not sure what
you're going to find probably about that
so we're going to have a good look and
hopefully we can remove
it okay let's get her right on the table
VCH Andrea assists in the procedure put
gloves on I'm serious it's terrible in
there see that's what it is you have to
go deep because you know I could feel
where the Lum was all the way through we
got to save as much possible because the
dog needs its tongue to eat and drink
okay I want to suture it afterwards too
yet we decided to do the cauterization
actually it just electric
cutting then it
stinks tongue is so fular that a lot of
blood vessels would be squirting all
over if he had just done it with the
knife and
scissors when Anthony was pulling it
back I was looking at the tissue and the
kn
God that's a hole in your tongue I hope
you can still swallow with this I don't
like these kind of tumors that grow that
fast and are in that soft tissue many
times there these oral carcinomas spread
very
fast it's not good we'll send the lump
in and see what it
is okay but time will tell the only
other alternative would be to put the
dog down and we were not ready for that
it looks normal tissue there yes it
does thank you suited everything leaning
is minimal there's now very little blood
loss it already completely quit bleeding
by the time the sutes were in
there and I hope things turn out it
looks to me like we got it off you never
get enough
off doc pole has done all he can do now
put it back in the next course of
treatment Andy even mti's life will
depend on the test results that come
back from the removed massive
tissue the snow's not letting up it's
going to be a tricky drive for thousands
of Thanksgiving holiday
Travelers when it's that snowy here you
can't
stop and you have to be very careful if
a dog comes running from the side
there's no way you can stop in time
a lady came up our driveway crying
saying she hit her
dog as he was drooling and he kind of
looked like he was going to die it's
okay he got hit by the car and he
actually ran to the back deck but his
one leg was wrapped around the other and
then when we laid him down he hasn't got
up since how bad he hasn't gotten up at
all there's his wound right there that's
the problem
so let's take X
first what Azie means to our family is
everything he's a happy dog he smiles a
lot he loves people my goodness gracious
you sweet everyone in the family loves
them so we're hoping for a good ending
here this is
[Music]
bad
after their dog was hit by a car Mark
and Carol Salters raced to the
clinic a lady came up our driveway
crying saying she hit her dog sorry we
were afraid that he had uh paralyzed his
hip and wouldn't be able to walk again
cuz he hadn't stood up since he'd been
hit it's okay our 12-year old boy uh
cried for about 2
hours and that uh upset me seeing him so
upset about
it x-rays will determine the extent of
azzie's
injuries okay so he the the right leg is
the one that's injured with all the
things here and it's out of place I have
to so this up pop it back in but he
live okay our son is going to be so
happy yeah yes we'll get busy with him
and I'll call you when I'm done with him
good boy Azie is going to
live but it's still uncertain if he'll
ever be able to walk
again not as much damage underneath as I
thought there was in there that's
helpful that looks good better than I
thought that heals up
good with a little Chiropractic
magic did you see that Aussie's
pops into place that was the most simple
one already is in hang on to that leg
just like that for me please and thank
you he's going to walk again but Dr Paul
needs to tame this road
warrior most of the time these dogs are
running the roads because there's
something going on down the
road a female and if this one had been
castrated he would not have been going
after that female he would not have been
HD in the road knew that animals do not
have a tendency to start wandering and
that's the whole
[Music]
secret Dr Paul gave us good news on Azie
being able to walk again looking good
I'm very relieved right
now good A's going to be fine and we'll
be able to take him back home this is
better than I thought to be honest with
you okay and I want to see him Thursday
probably a week from today yeah it's a
really good
day for Azie and his family this year's
Thanksgiving is going to be a good
one at his new home in Western New York
State come on baby the rescued Great
Dane Jackson seems to be doing just
fine Jackson's new home is on eight
glorious Acres come onab come on since
the operation that Dr pul had done he's
in no pain no discomfort the tip of his
tail totally healed and he is just
having the best life ever come on let's
go good boy it's that time of year when
the polls gather to celebrate Their
Blessings this Thanksgiving we're going
to celebrate the holidays by treating
the staff to a Thanksgiving dinner Amish
style this Thanksgiving I'm more
thankful because everybody is here and
everybody is healthy we had a good year
everybody's happy and feeling good
Dr Paul always loves the carcass of any
turkeys it gets to be kind of
embarrassing at times I just know now
that that's him and I let him go yeah I
love it it tastes good I like cartilage
the crunchiness is no problem and if you
don't so be it I'll take
yours some people might get embarrassed
when their father eating a carcass at a
turkey dinner but he's always a guy who
danced to the beat of his own drum so I
can appreciate that from our home to
yours Happy
[Music]
Thanksgiving